OK, good morning.
So today we are going to,
as I mentioned last week,
we've started the part of the
course where we are doing more
things having to do with design
than purely analysis.
Today, we're actually going to
do analysis, but it's the type
of analysis that leads to really
interesting design issues.
And we're going to follow it up
on Wednesday with an application
of the methods we're going to
learn today with a really
interesting and practical
problem.
So we're talking today about
amortized analysis.
And I want to motivate this
topic by asking the question,
how large should a hash table
be?
So, how large should a hash
table be?
Any suggestions?
You have got to make a hash
table, how big should I make it?
Let's say it's a simple hash
table, resolving collisions with
chaining.
How big should it be?
Twice as big as you need:
OK, how big would that be?
So, twice the number of
elements, for example,
OK.
As I increase the size of a
hash table, what happens to the
search time?
What happens to search time as
I increase the size of the hash
table?
Yeah, but what does it,
in general, do you?
It decreases,
right?
OK, the bigger I make it,
in fact, if I make it
sufficiently large,
then I essentially get a direct
access table,
and everything is worst-case,
order one time.
So in some sense,
we'll get back to your answer
in a minute.
We should make it as large as
possible, OK,
so that the searching is cheap.
The flipside of that is what?
It takes a lot of space so I
should make it as small as
possible so as not to waste
space.
So I want it big,
and the happy medium,
as we've discussed in our
analysis, is to make it order n
size for n items,
OK, because making it larger
than order n,
the payoff in search time is
not worth the extra amount of
space that you are paying.
OK, or at least you can view it
that way.
OK, however,
this begs the question,
which is, how do I make it,
if I start out with a hash
table, and I don't know how many
elements are going to be hashed
into it?
OK, how big should I make it?
OK, so what if we don't know --
-- in advance?
OK, what if we don't know n?
OK, so the solution to this
problem turns out it's fairly
elegant?
It's a strategy called dynamic
tables.
OK, and the idea is that
whenever the table gets too many
elements in it,
gets too full,
OK, so the idea is --
-- OK, and we say that says the
table overflows,
OK, we grow it and make a
bigger table.
So, for hashing,
although there's going to be no
point at which you could say
that it overflows in the sense
that it wouldn't be functional
at least if it was done with
chaining.
There would be,
by the way, if you were doing
it with open addressing.
But let's say with chaining,
when it gets too big,
say, as many elements as the
size of the table,
what we do is we grow the
table.
So, the way we do that as we
allocate using,
in a language like C,
it's called Malloc,
or in a language like Java
called New, a larger table.
So, we create a larger table.
We move the items from the old
table to the new.
And then, we free the old
table.
So, let's do an example.
So, let's say I have,
over here, a table of size one,
and it's empty to begin with.
And I do an insert.
So what I do is stick it in the
table.
It fits.
OK, so here,
I'm not going to do it with
hashing.
I'm just going to do it as if I
just had a table that I was
filling up with elements to
abstract the problem.
But it would work with hashing.
It would work with any kind of
fixed size data structure.
I insert again,
oops, doesn't fit.
I get an overflow.
OK, so what I do is I create a
new, actually,
I'm going to need a little more
space than that.
I create a new table of size
two, doubling the size.
And, I copy the old value into
the new.
I freed this one,
and now I can insert item two.
So, I do it again.
I get another overflow.
So now, I make a table of size
four.
I copied these guys in,
and then I insert my number
three.
I do insert here.
I do five.
I guess I should be using ditto
marks.
That would be a lot smarter.
Whoops, what am I doing?
I overflow.
And now, I make one of size
eight, OK, copy these over,
and now I can insert five.
And I can do six,
seven, etc.,
OK?
Does everybody understand the
basic idea?
So, whenever I overflow,
I'm going to create a table of
twice the size.
OK, so let's do a quick
analysis of this.
So, we have a sequence of n
insertion operations.
OK, what is the worst-case cost
of one insert operation?
What's the worst case for any
one of these?
Yeah, it's order n,
whatever the overhead is of
copying; if we counted it as
one, it would be basically n or
n plus one because we've got to
copy all those.
OK, so it's order n.
So therefore,
if I have n of those,
so the worst-case cost of n
inserts is equal to n times
order n, which is order n^2.
Any questions?
Does that make sense?
Raise hands.
Yeah, not all of them can be
worst-case, good.
And in fact,
this is totally wrong analysis.
Just because one can be
worst-case order n doesn't mean
n are necessarily order n.
OK, so this is totally wrong
analysis.
n inserts, in fact,
take order n time in the worst
case.
OK, it doesn't take order n^2.
So, the analysis is correct up
to the point where we set the
worst-case of one insert was
order n.
Therefore, that's the wrong
step.
OK, whenever you see bugs in
proofs, you want to know,
which step is the one that
failed so you can make sure that
you don't have a confusion
there?
So, let's do the proper
analysis, OK?
So let's let c_i be the cost of
the i'th insert.
OK, so that's equal to i,
if i minus one is an exact
power of two.
And it's one otherwise.
OK, so as I was going through
here, it was only when I
inserted something where the
previous one had been the exact
power of two,
because that was my table size.
That's when I got the overflow
and had to do all that copying.
And otherwise,
the cost, for example,
for inserting six,
was just one.
I just inserted it.
Does everybody see that?
So, let's actually make a
little table here so we can see
this a little bit more clearly.
OK, so here's i,
and in the size of the table at
step i, and the cost at step i.
OK, so let's see,
the size of i,
let's see, at step one it was
one.
At step two,
it was two.
And at step three,
that's when,
to get three in the table,
we had to double the size here.
So, this is four,
and four, it fit.
And then five,
it had to bump up to eight.
And then, six,
it was eight.
Seven, it was eight.
Eight, it was eight.
And nine, it bumps up to 16,
16, etc.
So that's the size.
And let's take a look at what
the cost was.
So, the cost here was one,
OK, to insert one.
The cost here was,
I had to copy one,
and then insert one.
So, the cost was two.
Here, I had to copy two and
insert one.
So, the cost was three.
Here, I had to just insert one.
So, the cost was one.
Here, I had to copy four and
insert one.
So, the cost was five.
Excuse me?
I think it is.
Yeah, see, it's i cost.
The cost for five is i,
OK, is five if this is a power
of two.
OK, one, one,
and now we paid nine,
and then one again.
So that's the cost we are
paying.
It's a little bit easier to see
what the costs are if I break
them down.
OK, so let's just redraw this
as two values because there is
always the cost for inserting
the one thing that I want to
insert.
And now, the residual amount
that I have to pay is I have to
pay one here.
I've got to pay two additional,
four additional,
eight additional.
That makes the pattern a little
bit easier to see.
OK, this is the cost of copying
versus the cost of just doing
the actual insert,
OK?
Now, if you're taking notes,
leave some space here because
I'm going to come back to this
table later.
OK, so leave a little bit of
space because I'm going to come
back and add some more things at
there at a later time.
OK, so, I can then just add up
the cost of n inserts.
That's just the sum,
I equals one to n of c_i,
which is equal to,
well, by this analysis it is
essentially n because that's
what this thing adds up to plus
I just have to add the powers of
two up to but not exceeding
whatever my n was.
So, if I do my algebra properly
there, that's up to the floor of
log n minus one,
OK, of two to the J.
So, I'm just adding up all the
powers of two up to that aren't
going to exceed my n.
And, this is what type of
series?
That's geometric.
That's geometric,
so it is bounded by its largest
term.
Its largest term is two to the
ceiling; it's dominated by its
largest term,
two to the ceiling of log n
minus one, which is,
at most, n.
OK, and then all the other
terms at up to,
at most, n.
So this is actually less than
or equal to 3n,
which is order n as we want it
to show.
OK, that's algebra.
OK, so, thus,
the average cost per insert is
theta of n over n,
which is theta one.
So, the average cost of an
insert is order one,
which is what we would like it
to be especially if we're
building hash tables.
Even though sometimes you have
to pay a big price with
amortized over the previous
insertions that we've done,
so that the overall cost of n
operations is order n.
And that's the notion of
amortized analysis,
OK, that if I look at a
sequence of operations,
I can spread the cost out over
a whole bunch of operations,
so that the average cost is
order n.
So, if we sort of summarize
that, OK, OK,
with basically an amortized
analysis, we analyze a sequence
of operations to show that the
average cost per operation is
small, even though one
operation, or several,
even, may be expensive.
OK, there's no probability.
Even though we're doing it with
averages, there's no probability
going on.
OK, what you do probability,
and you are looking at means,
there's averages.
OK, here's average,
but there's no probability
going on.
It's average performance in the
worst case because n operations
take me a constant amount of
time per operation in the worst
case.
n operations take me order n
time.
OK, each operation takes order
one time, OK,
but it's amortized over the n
operations, OK?
Yeah, question?
Yes.
Yes, yes, you can mix,
but you don't have to.
Yeah, but the point is that the
basic amortized analysis is
actually saying something very
strong.
It's giving you worst-case
bounds, but over a sequence as
opposed to looking at each
individual element of the
sequence.
Now, there are three types of
amortized arguments that appear
in the literature.
Maybe there are more.
At one point,
there were two.
And then, a third one was
developed.
So, maybe there's a fourth.
The first one is an aggregate,
what's called an aggregate
analysis.
And this is what we just saw,
OK, where basically you just
analyze, what do the n
operations take?
OK, and then we're going to see
two more today.
One is called an accounting
argument, and the other is a
potential argument.
These two are more precise
because they allocate specific
amortized costs to each
operation.
So, one of the things about the
aggregate analysis is that you
can't really say what the
amortized cost of a single
operation is easily.
You can in this case.
You can say it's order one,
OK?
But, in the accounting and
potential arguments,
it gives you a much more
precise way of characterizing
what an amortized cost of a
particular operation is.
So, let's pitch in and look at
the accounting method as our
first method.
So, these we're going to go
through the exact same example.
In some sense,
this example,
the easiest argument to make is
the aggregate analysis.
OK, so we're going get into
arguments that,
in some sense,
see more complicated.
But it turns out that these
methods are more powerful in
many circumstances.
OK, and so I want to do it in a
simple situation where you have
some sort of appreciation of the
fact that you can look at any
particular problem and approach
it from different ways.
OK, so the accounting method is
putting yourself in the position
of a financial accountant.
So what you do is we are going
to charge the i'th operation a
fictitious amortized cost.
We'll call it c hat sub i,
where we are going to use the
abstraction that $1 pays for one
unit of work.
There's Time manipulating the
data structure or whatever.
OK, so the idea is you charge
the cost.
You say, this operation will
cost you $5 or whatever.
OK, and that phi is consumed to
perform the operation,
but there may be some unused
part.
So, if there's any unused
amount, it's going to be stored
in the bank for use by later
operations.
So the idea is that if the phi
that is being paid,
the c_i hat phi,
isn't sufficient to pay for
performing the operation,
then you take money out of the
bank to pay for it.
OK, and so you don't get
arrested, what's the property
that you've got to have?
You've got to have the bank
balance.
What about the bank balance?
What mathematical fact has to
hold the bank balance?
Yeah, it better be greater than
or equal to zero,
right?
Most people are familiar with
that.
So, the bank balance must not
go negative.
In other words,
the amortized costs minus the
costs of the operations up to
that point have to always be
enough to pay for all the
operations that you're doing.
Otherwise, you're borrowing on
the future.
In amortized analysis,
we don't borrow on the future,
at least not on the simple ones
that we are doing here.
OK, so that means we must have
that the sum,
I equals one to n of c_i,
the true costs,
therefore, if the balance is
not going to ever go negative,
must be bounded above by the
amortized costs for all n.
OK, for the bank balance not to
go negative, if I add up the
true costs, it's got to be the
case that I can always pay for
them.
This is what I'm charging.
This is what it actually costs
me.
So, it better be the case that
whatever I've actually had to
pay to operate on that data
structure, that's what this is,
better be covered by the amount
that I've been charging people
for the use of that data
structure up to that point.
And that's got to be true for
all n.
But notice that this now gives
me a way of charging a
particular operation a certain
amount.
So, the total amortized costs
provide an upper bound on the
total true costs.
Total amortized costs are an
upper bound on the true costs.
Any question about this?
That we'll do the example of
the dynamic table using this
methodology.
OK, so, back to the dynamic
table.
OK, so what we're going to do
in this case is we're going to
charge an amortized cost of $3
for the i'th insert for all i.
And the idea is that $1 is
going to pay for an immediate
insert, and $2 is going to be
stored for doubling the table.
And, it needs to be expanded.
When the table doubles,
of the stored dollars,
we'll use one dollar to move a
recent item, I'll call it,
and one dollar we'll move an
old item.
So, let's do the example.
So, imagine that I'm in this
situation where I have a table
of size eight,
and I just doubled my table.
So I have four items of the
table.
What I'm going to do is have no
dollars in my table.
So, along comes an insertion of
item number five.
I charge $3 for it.
$1 lets me put the item in the
table, and I have $2 left over.
So let me store those $2 in the
slot corresponding to where that
item is.
Now, item six comes in.
Once again, $1,
charge $3, $1 is paid for the
insert, $2 left over,
I'm going to play $2.
Let me put it down there,
and so forth.
The next one comes in,
$2, $2 leftover,
and now the ninth item comes
in.
So, I double the size of my
table.
OK, and now I copy all of these
guys and to all of these here.
And what happens?
Look at that:
I've got $8,
and I've got eight items that
have to be copied.
Perfect.
OK, so one of these dollars
pays for one of the ones that
was inserted in the last round,
and one of them pays for an old
one.
OK, and so, I copy them in,
and now, none of those guys
have any money.
And the ninth guy comes in:
he has $2 left over.
And then, we keep going on.
OK, so you see that by that
argument, if I charge everybody
$3, OK, I can always handle all
of the table doubling,
the charges for the table
doubling because the inductive
invariant that I've maintained
is that after it doubles,
there's nothing in the bank
account.
And now, I put in $2.
Well then, I can pay,
and I'm now left in the same
situation.
OK, and it's the case that the
bank balance never goes
negative.
So that's a really important
invariant to verify.
And so, therefore,
the sum of the true costs,
or the amortized costs,
upper bound the sum of the true
costs.
And, since the sum of the
amortized cost,
here, is, if I go i equals one
to n, OK, this is 3n.
So, the point is,
now I bounded the sum of the
true costs by 3n.
OK, so let's go back to this
table here, and look to see what
happens, OK, if I put in c_i
hat, and the bank balance.
OK, so in fact,
so the first thing I do is
insert; I charge $3,
right, and I do an insert.
How much do I have left?
I'm going to have $2.
It turns out I'm actually going
to charge $2 and have only $1
left.
OK, so I'm actually going to
under charge the first guy.
I'm going to show you that it
works if I charge everybody $3.
Except the first guy:
I charge $2.
I can actually save a little
bit on number one.
OK, that for this guy I'm going
to charge $3.
OK, what's the size of my bank
balance when I'm done?
Well, I have to copy one guy.
He's all paid for,
so I have $2 left.
OK, people with me?
OK, the next guy:
I charge $3.
Actually, I'm going to charge
all these guys $3.
OK, so here now I basically get
to, I've got a table of size
four.
So, I basically have,
I have to copy,
oh, when I insert the third
guy, I've got to copy two guys.
That'll use up that,
so I'll have only $2 left in
the table after I've inserted
him.
OK, now I insert the fourth
guy, OK, and that's a good one
because now I've built up a
balance here of $4 because I
didn't have to copy anybody.
OK, now I insert the fifth guy.
I've got to copy four items.
So that expends that balance.
I have, then,
two left.
OK, and then here basically I
add two to it.
And then at this point,
I use it all up and go back to
two, etc.
OK, so you see one of the
things I want you to notice is I
could have charged three here.
And then I would've had an
extra dollar lying around
throughout here.
It wouldn't have mattered.
It still would be upper bounded
by 3n.
OK, so the idea is that
different schemes for charging
amortized costs can work.
They don't all have to be the
same.
It's not like when you do in
amortized analysis that there is
one scheme that will work.
I could have charged $4 to
everybody.
And it would have worked.
But it turns out,
I couldn't have charged two
dollars for everybody.
If I charged $2 for everybody,
my balance would go negative,
OK?
My balance would go negative,
but I can charge three dollars,
and that will work.
OK, four, five,
six, I could charge that.
The bound that I would get
would be simply a looser bound.
Instead of it being less than
or equal to 3n,
it would be less than or equal
to 4n or 5n, or what have you.
But if I tried to do 2n,
it wouldn't have worked because
I wouldn't have enough money
left to copy everything.
What would happen is I would
have only $1 in this,
and then when it came time to
table double,
I would need to copy eight
guys.
And I'd only have built up a
bank account of $4,
sorry, if I charged $2 and had
$1 left over.
OK, so to actually make these
things work out,
you have to play a little bit,
OK, see what works,
see what doesn't work.
OK, no algorithmic formulas for
algorithm design.
OK, good.
In the book,
you can read about table
contraction.
What happens when you start
deleting elements?
Now you want to make the table
be smaller.
Now, you have to be very
careful because unless you put,
who remembers from physics,
hysteresis?
Vaguely?
A couple people?
OK, you have to worry about
hysteresis.
OK, if you're not careful,
if whenever it gets to be less
than a power of two,
you go in the half,
you can find that you're
thrashing.
So, you need to make it so that
there is some memory in the
system so that you only collapse
after you've done a sufficient
number of deletions,
OK, and so forth.
And the book has analysis of
the more general case.
OK, so any questions about the
accounting method?
Accounting method is really
very cute, OK,
very cute.
And, it's the one most students
prefer to do,
OK?
They usually hate the next one
until they learn it.
Once they learn it,
they say, ooh,
that's cool.
OK, but to start out with,
it takes a little bit more
intestinal fortitude,
OK?
But it's amazing.
Good potential arguments are
really sweet.
And we are going to see one
next time, so you'll definitely
want to review and make sure you
understand it before Wednesday's
lecture because Wednesday's
lecture, we're going to assume
we understand potential method.
OK, so let's do,
enough advertisement.
I think the potential method is
one of the beautiful results in
algorithmic analysis,
OK, just beautiful result,
beautiful set of techniques.
OK, and it's also,
just in terms of,
I mean, what do you aspire:
to be a bookkeeper or to be a
physicist?
OK, so, the idea is we don't
want to be bankers.
We want to be physicists.
And so, this bank account,
we are going to say about the
potential energy of the dynamics
that that we are analyzing.
OK, because,
why?
It delivers up work just like a
spring does, for example,
OK, when you study potential
energy, or putting something up
high and having gravity pull it
down.
We convert dynamic to
potential, and that's exactly
what we're going to be doing
here, and it's similar
mathematics except that in our
case it turns out to be discrete
mathematics rather than
continuous math for most of it.
So here's the framework for the
potential method.
So, we start with some data
structure, D_0,
and operation i transforms D_(i
- 1) into D_i.
So, we view the operation on
the data structure as a mapping,
mapping one data structure to
another data structure,
the one from before to the one
after.
OK, already it's nicely
mathematical.
OK, and of course,
the costs of operation i
remains at c_i.
And, now what we are going to
do is define the potential
function, phi,
which maps the set of data
structures into the reals.
So, associated with every data
structure, now,
is a potential,
OK, a real-valued potential,
often integer potential such
that phi of D_0 is equal to
zero.
So, the initial potential is
zero, and phi of D_i is greater
than or equal to zero for all i.
So, potential can never be
nonnegative, just like the bank
account because the potential is
essentially representing the
bank account,
if you will,
in the accounting method.
OK, so we always want the
potential to be nonnegative.
Now, actually,
there are times where you use
potential functions where you
violate both of these
properties.
There's some really interesting
potential arguments which don't
violate like these,
but for the simple ones we're
going to be doing in this class,
we'll just assume that these
tend to be true.
OK, but we will actually see
some times where phi of D_0
isn't zero, it doesn't matter.
OK, but generally this is what
we are going to assume in the
type of potential function
argument that we are going to be
doing.
OK, so I just want to let you
know that there are bigger,
there is a bigger space of
potential function arguments
than the one that I'm showing
you here.
OK, so then,
under this circumstance,
we define the amortized cost
c_i hat with respect to phi as,
and this is one of these
formulas that if you can't
remember it, definitely put it
down on your crib sheet for the
final.
OK, so c_i hat is equal to c_i
plus phi of D_i minus phi of D_i
minus one.
OK, so this is the change in
potential difference.
And, let's call it delta phi i
for shorthand.
OK, and let's see what it means
to have --
-- in the different
circumstances.
So, if delta of phi i is
greater than zero,
OK, so if this is greater than
zero, then what's the
relationship between c_i hat and
c_i?
This is greater than zero.
Yeah, c_i hat is then greater
than c_i, OK?
Then, c_i hat is greater than
c_i.
And what does that mean?
That means when I do operation
I, I charged more than it cost
me to do the operation.
So, the extra amount that I
charged beyond what I actually
used is being put into the bank,
OK, is being stored as
potential energy.
So, op I stores work in the
data structure for later.
Similarly, if delta phi i is
less than zero,
then c_i hat is less than c_i.
And so, the data structure
delivers up work --
-- to help pay for op I,
OK, for operation I.
So, if it's less than zero,
that means that my change in
potential, that means my bank
account went down as a result,
and so therefore,
what happens was the data
structure provided work to be
done in order,
because the true cost was
bigger than the amortized cost.
So, if you think about it,
the difference between looking
at it from the potential
function point of view versus
the accounting point of view,
you sort of say,
here is what my amortized cost
will be.
Now let me analyze my bank
account, make sure it never went
negative.
In some sense,
in the potential function
argument, you're saying,
here's what my bank account is
all the time.
Now let me analyze what the
amortized costs are.
So, that's sort of the
difference in approaches.
One is you are sort of
specifying the bank account.
The other, you're specifying
the amortized costs.
So, we look at the,
why is it that this is a
reasonable way to proceed?
Well, let's look at the total
amortized cost of n operations.
OK, that's just the sum,
i equals one to n of c_i hat.
That's the total amortized
cost.
And that's equal to,
but substitution,
just substitute c_i hat for
this formula.
OK, so that's c_i plus phi of
D_i minus phi of D_i minus one.
OK, and that's equal to c_i.
And now, what happens when I
sum up these terms?
What happens when some of these
terms?
What's the mathematical term we
use?
It telescopes.
OK, every term on the left is
added in once when it's I,
and subtract it out when it's I
minus one, except for the first
and last terms.
The term for n is only added
in, and the term for zero is
only subtracted out.
OK, so that's because it
telescopes.
OK, so this term is what?
What property do we know of
this?
It's greater than or equal to
zero.
And this one equals zero.
So, therefore,
this is greater than or equal
to c_i.
And thus, the amortized costs
are an upper bound on the true
costs, which is what we want.
Some of the amortized costs is
an upper bound up on the sum of
the true costs.
OK, but here,
the way that we define the
amortized costs was by first
defining the potential function.
OK, so the potential function
is sort of, as I said,
the difference between the
accounting and the potential
method is, do you specify the
bank account or do you specify
the cost?
OK, do you specify the
potential energy at any point,
or do you specify the cost at
any point?
OK, but in any case,
you get, this bound,
also this math is nicer math.
I like telescopes.
OK, so the amortized costs
upper bound the true costs.
OK, let's do table doubling
over here.
So, to analyze this,
we have to define our
potential.
OK, if anybody can guess this
off the top of their head,
they're better than I am.
I struggled with this for
probably easily a couple hours
to get it right,
OK, because I'm not too smart.
OK, that's a potential function
I'm going to use,
OK, 2i minus two to the ceiling
of log i.
And, we're going to assume that
two to the ceiling of log of
zero is equal to zero,
because that's what it is in
the limit.
For log of zero,
this becomes minus infinity,
so, two to the minus infinity
is zero.
So, that's just going to be a
mathematical convenience.
Assume that.
OK, so where did I get this
from?
I played around.
I looked at that sequence that
I have erased and I said,
OK, because reversing,
there are some problems for
which defining a potential
function is fairly easy.
But, defining the amortized
costs is hard,
OK, to define the accounting.
So, for this one,
the accounting method is,
I would say,
an easier method to use.
However, I'm going to show you
that you still can do it with
potential method if you come up
with the right potential.
So, intuitively,
this is basically what's left
in the bank account at the I'th
operation because I've put in 2i
things into the bank,
and I've subtracted out this
many, essentially,
from table doublings,
OK, up to that point,
OK?
So, first let's observe,
what is phi of D_0?
Zero.
So, that's good.
And, the phi of D_i is greater
than or equal to zero.
Why is that?
So, what's the biggest that
ceiling of log i could be?
Ceiling of log i is either log
i or log i quantity plus one,
OK?
So, the biggest it is,
is log i plus one.
If it's log i plus one,
two to the log i plus one,
it's just 2i.
That's the biggest it could be,
right?
So, two, the log of i,
plus one, is just,
let's do it the other way,
is i times two,
OK, i for that part,
two for that part.
OK, so that the biggest it
could be.
OK, or it's just log of i.
So, either this is going to be
2i minus i or 2i minus 2i.
In either case,
it's bigger than zero,
OK?
So, those are the two
properties I need for this to be
a well-defined potential
function.
Now, that doesn't say that the
amortized costs are going to be
satisfied the property that
things are going to be cheap,
OK, that I'm going to be able
to do my analysis and get the
kind of bounds I want.
But, it sets up to say,
yes, I've satisfied the syntax
of having a proper potential
function.
So, let's just do a quick
example here just to see what
this means.
So, imagine that I am in the
situation where I have eight,
did I do that right,
OK, yeah, eight slots,
and say six of them are full.
So then, phi by this is going
to be 2i.
That's two times six minus two
to the 2i.
What's that?
Sorry, minus two to the ceiling
of log i.
So, i is six,
right, so log of i is log of
six.
The ceiling of it is three.
So, that's minus 2^3,
which is eight.
So, that's 12 minus eight.
That's four.
And if you think about this in
the accounting method,
these would be zeros,
and these would be twos,
right, for the accounting
method if we do the same thing,
because this is halfway
through, right,
all zeros, and that we add two
for each one that we're going
in.
So, I function is,
in fact, telling me what the
actual cost is.
OK, everybody with me?
OK, so that's what we mean by
this particular potential
function.
OK, so now let's add up the
amortized cost of the i'th
insert.
OK, so that's the amortized
cost of the i'th insert,
just by definition.
OK, and now that's equal to,
well, what is c_i?
Do we still have that written
down somewhere,
or have we erased that at this
point?
I think we erased it.
Well, we can write it down
again.
It is i if i minus one is an
exact power of two.
And, it's one otherwise.
That's c_i.
That's this term,
plus, and now phi of D_i:
so, what is that?
phi of D_i is this business,
2i minus two ceiling of log i
minus 2i minus one minus two
ceiling of log of I minus one.
OK, so that's the amortized
cost.
That's a nice,
pretty formula,
right?
OK, let's hope it simplifies a
little.
OK, so that's equal to,
well, we have the i and the one
here, if, etc.,
that business,
plus, OK, well,
we have some things we can
cancel here, right?
So here, we have 2i minus 2i.
That cancels.
And then we have what's left
over here is a minus two.
So, that's a plus two.
And now, I have minus this term
plus this term.
That's a lot prettier.
OK, it's still a mess.
We've got to case analysis.
Why is it suggestive of a case
analysis?
We have a case.
OK, so let's do a case
analysis.
OK, so case one,
I minus one is an exact power
of two.
So then, c_i hat is equal to,
well, c_i is now just i.
That's that case.
And then we have the rest
there, plus two,
minus two, ceiling of log i
minus two ceiling of log of i
minus one.
OK, and that's equal to i plus
two.
Well, let's see.
If I minus one is an exact
power of two,
what is this term?
i minus one is an exact power
of two.
Plus, thank you,
sorry about that.
It's good to have students,
let me say, because,
boy, my math is so bad.
This is actually why I end up
being a pretty good theoretician
is because I don't ever trust
what I've written down.
And so, I write it down in a
way that I can verify it because
otherwise I just am not smart
enough to carry through five
equations in a row and expect
that everyone is going to be
transformed appropriately.
OK, so you write it down.
So I always write it down so I
can verify it.
And that fortunately has the
side benefit that other people
can understand what I've done as
well.
OK, so what is this one?
This is two to the log of i
minus one because the ceiling,
if this is an exact power of
two, right, then ceiling of log
of i minus one is just log of i
minus one.
So, this is two to the log of i
minus one, which is i minus one,
right?
Yeah?
OK.
OK, if it's an exact power of
two, then the log is an integer,
right?
So, taking the ceiling,
it doesn't matter,
get rid of the ceiling.
OK, this one,
however, is not an exact power
of two.
But what is it?
It's just one more than this
guy.
We know that i minus one is not
an exact power of two,
so it's going to be the next
bigger one.
OK, so that means this is what?
So, it's going to be,
how do these two compare?
How much bigger is this one
than this one?
It's twice the size.
We know what this one is.
OK, or it can reason it from
first principles.
This is going to be the log of
i minus one plus one.
OK, and so then you can reduce
it to this.
So, you've got to think about
those floors and ceilings,
right?
It's like, what's happening in
the round off there?
OK, so now we can simplify
this.
OK, so what do we have here?
We have, OK,
so if I multiply this through,
I have an i plus two minus 2i
plus two plus i minus one.
I know a lot of you,
probably 90% of you will do
this step.
You will go directly from this
step to the last step.
And that's where 30% of you,
or some number,
will get it wrong.
OK, so let me encourage you to
do that step.
OK, it's easier to find your
bugs if you take it slow.
Actually, taking it slow is
faster in the long run.
It's hard to teach young
stallions, or phillies,
or whatever,
OK?
Just take it easy.
Just patience,
just do it slow,
get it right.
It's actually faster.
OK, everybody knows the
tortoise and hare story.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
OK, but nobody believes it.
OK, so now here we have 2i
here, an i here,
and an i here.
And then, that leaves us with
two plus two minus one,
equals three.
Awesome, awesome.
OK, amortized cost is three
when i minus one is an exact
power of two.
OK, case two.
OK, i minus one is not an exact
power of two.
So then we have c_i hat is
equal to, now instead of i it's
one plus, and then the two minus
two to the ceiling of log i plus
two to the ceiling of log of i
minus one.
OK, now what can somebody tell
me about these two terms in the
case where i minus one is not an
exact power of two?
What are they?
Equal.
Why is that?
Yeah, the ceiling is going to
do the same thing to both,
going to take it up to the same
integer.
So these two things are equal,
which means this is equal to
three.
OK, so therefore,
n inserts, OK,
so now I say,
oh, the amortized cost is three
for every operation for every
insert.
So therefore,
n inserts costs,
well, the amortized cost of
each is three.
So n of them,
the amortized cost is 3n.
That's an upper bound on the
worst-case true costs.
So, n inserts costs order n in
the worst case.
OK, there is a bug in this
analysis.
It's a minor bug.
It's the one I pointed out
before the first insert has
amortized cost of two,
and not three.
I didn't actually deal with
that one carefully enough.
OK, so that's an exercise to
just go and look to see where it
is that that happens and how you
show that, in fact,
the amortized cost of the first
one is two, OK,
where that shows up.
OK, so to summarize,
actually let me summarize over
here, conclusions about
amortized analysis.
So amortized costs provide a
clean abstraction for data
structure performance.
So, what I can tell somebody,
so suppose I built a dynamic
table, for example,
OK.
It's easier to say,
in terms of your own
performance modeling,
it costs a constant amount of
time for each insert.
As long as you don't care about
real-time behavior,
but only the aggregate
behavior, that's a great
abstraction for the performance
Rather than saying it's got
that complicated thing which
sometimes cost you a lot,
how do they reason about that?
But you could say every
operation costs me order one,
that's really simple.
But they have to understand,
it's order one in an amortized
sense, OK.
So, if they do have a real-time
constraint to make,
amortized doesn't cut it.
OK, but for many problems,
it's perfectly good.
It lets me explain it rather
simply.
OK, we will see some other data
structures that have amortized
costs where different operations
have different amortized costs.
And the nice thing about that
is I just add up,
what's the cost of all my
different operations,
OK, where there is a different
cost for each operation?
Some will be log n.
Some will be order one,
or whatever.
Add them up:
that's an upper bound on the
true costs.
OK: tremendous simplification
in abstracting and reasoning
about those complicated data
structures.
OK, now, so this is probably,
this is huge.
OK, abstraction,
you know, computer science,
what teach you through four
years of undergraduate,
and another year if you go on
to M.Eng., and then if you get a
Ph.D., it's another 15 years or
whatever it takes to get a Ph.D.
OK, all you teach about is
abstraction: abstraction,
abstraction,
abstraction.
So, this is a powerful
abstraction: quite good.
Now, we learned three methods.
In general, any method can be
used.
You can convert one to the
other.
But each has situations where
it is arguably simplest or most
precise.
So, any of the methods can be
used.
However, you must learn all of
them, OK, because there are
going to be some situations
where you need one,
where it's better to do one,
better to do another.
If you're reading in the
literature, you want to know
these different ways of doing
it.
And that means that even though
you may get really comfortable
with accounting,
OK, in an exam,
or whatever,
I may say solve this with a
potential function argument.
So, you want to be comfortable
with all the methods,
OK.
Last point is that,
in fact, different potential
functions or accounting costs
may yield different bounds.
OK, so when you do an amortized
analysis, there's nothing to say
that one set of costs is better
than another.
So, just as an example,
OK, in any data structure
generally that supports delete,
I can amortize all the deletes
against the inserts.
So, in general,
what I could do is say deletes
are free, OK,
and charge twice as much for
each insert.
OK, charging enough when I do
the insert to amortize it
against the delete.
That you could do with an
accounting method.
You can also do it with a
potential method,
the potential,
then, being the number of items
that I actually have in my data
structure times the cost of the
delete for each of those items.
OK, so the point is that I can
allocate costs in different
ways.
Or I could have amortized costs
which are equal to the true
costs.
So, there are different ways
that I could assign amortized
costs.
There is no one way,
OK, and choosing different ones
may yield different bounds.
It may not, but it may yield
different bounds.
OK, generally it does yield
different ones.
OK, next time:
an amazing use of potential
functions.
OK, the stuff is cool,
but let me tell you,
Wednesday's lecture:
amazing.
Amazing the type of analysis we
are going to be able to do.